here's a trademark law fun fact for you
the copyright on Mickey Mouse expires in
2024 which means everyone's favorite
anthropomorphic rodent will fall into
the public domain on january first of
that year I mean that'll probably change
because Disney is rolling in cash but
still fun fact I'm gate and this is your
gamespot news update the United States
Patent and Trademark offer has refused
an application by Sony to trademark
let's play Sony filed the application on
October 28 and hopes to trademark the
term for use in a variety of fields
including streaming of games and
audio-visual material the USPTO has
since responded refusing the trademark
due to a similarity to one that already
exists on LP let's play because of the
confusingly similar names this doesn't
necessarily spell the end of Sony's
attempt to acquire the trademark from
the time of the refusal December 29th
2015 sony has six months to respond
Sony's intentions for the trademark are
unknown when contacted last week it said
it had nothing further to share on the
trademark in question while some might
assume it could be used to prevent the
gaming community from labeling their
let's play style videos as such it seems
unlikely Sony would burn through the
goodwill it's and since the unveiling of
the ps4 in any event will keep an eye on
the status of the trademark should Sony
decide to move forward do you think this
is a step too far from Sony let me know
in the comments or come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw remember
to keep it gamespot com for all your
video game updates and thanks for
watching